this sacred institution wields power
beyond your imagination the John worth
movie franchise has proven to be a
money-making critical darling fan loving
Juggernaut I've officially run out of
two word descriptors but you get the
point so naturally more projects in that
world are coming starting with a
three-part prequel event on peacock so
here's everything you need to know
before you watch the Continental Jerome
show our guests the door
so before you check in
through this show here's what we're
gonna check out a brief history of the
John Wick franchise to this point what
is the Continental both the show and
well the building who are the characters
and who made it all happen besides just
Keanu Reeves is General greatness okay
let's go so do we need a John Wick movie
recap well that's basically asking if we
need more Keanu Reeves in our lives and
the answer is unequivocally and always
yes but I promise we'll make it quick so
the first movie kicked off the franchise
in 2014 introducing keanu's John Wick
character a retired and legendary
assassin who basically sets out for some
serious Revenge after his super cute
puppy is killed now I actually love the
puppy's name Daisy so much that I gave
Keanu Reeves a bouquet of daisies when I
sat down with him for an exclusive John
Wick chapter 4 interview for Rotten
Tomatoes so check that out on YouTube if
you haven't already but this first film
actually set the tone in a couple of
ways starting with Mr Reeves himself who
if you didn't know did 90 of his own
Sons after doing intense weapons and
martial arts train training for four
months prior it also helped that first
time and so far only director Chad
stachowski worked with Keanu as a stunt
double on The Matrix trilogy isn't that
so cool so in other words safe to say
they're not going to be messing around
when it came to action and of course
John Wick kicked open the door for
multiple sequels each one more
successful than the last by the way
along with video games and comic books
and all the franchisee type things
2017's John Wick chapter 2 found the
lead character once again forced back
into his old life this time to fulfill
an oath to a crime Lord now our boy
Keanu added in Jiu Jitsu driving and
Marksmanship training to his workout
plan this time around and what do you
know chapter 2 earned double the first
ones 86 million dollar haul insane it
also happens to include my favorite Wick
fight of all time the pencil fight I
mean the man can kill people by pencil
moving on to chapter 3 Parabellum which
came in 2019 and it found Jon as the one
with a Target on his head this time as
he was being chased by the world's most
ruthless Killers now big deal now John
week chapter four arrived in 2023 with
JW now seeking revenge against those who
had previously left him for dead and it
somehow managed to make more money and
earn higher Tomato Meter and audience
scores than his predecessors I mean the
better it gets the better it gets and I
mean geez no pressure for the
Continental I guess and maybe we should
start talking about that because that's
why you're here so speaking of the
Continental what exactly is it besides
you know a kind of breakfast of course
sorry I couldn't resist a one admission
for the continental breakfast so in the
world of John Wick the Continental is an
international Syndicate of luxury hotels
catering to Big Time criminals where
assassination assignments are safely
exchanged using special gold coins that
are pressed in and distributed by the
house so there's also a bunch of rules
like a no violence policy ironically
enough enforced by the guy who runs it
Winston Scott played brilliantly by Ian
McShane in the movies enjoy your stay at
Continental so this new three-part
series is going to explore not only the
origin of the hotel but also how Winston
came into the position that he's had for
40 years when we meet him in the first
John Wick movie and since they are going
back 40 years in this prequel spin-off
the choice was made to reflect a
historically gritty time in the 1970s
when New York was bankrupt and Newark
was pretty much on fire and the streets
of Manhattan were basically in the
middle of a garbage strike and had
literally become a dump I mean is this
one the whole rat thing started over
there no I'm just kidding I'm not the
rat no but seriously though the
Continental is the Beating Heart of this
franchise and once I heard that there
was going to be a TV show about it I was
sold because when I saw the hotel scenes
play out in the first film I was
obsessed and I wanted to know more so I
can't wait to learn more about this
hotel and honestly what their robes look
like I can't resist a good hotel robe
you know how about the lining
tactical all right let's get into the
who is who of it all so as you imagine
We're not gonna see a ton of familiar
characters given the 40-year difference
and the short lifespan that goes with
the Assassin profession I would imagine
but we are gonna meet a young Winston
Scott played by Colin Waddell who you
might remember as the unlikely villain
on the flight attendant so the director
Albert Hughes who did the first and
third episodes actually compared Colin
to guys like Clark Gable Humphrey bogar
and Harrison Ford I mean that is that's
high praise the other character that
you're gonna know already is Sharon
Winston's right-hand man who's played by
the late Lance Reddick in the movies and
is just an icon in the franchise for the
Continental that honor will go to
ayomide Aragon in his first ever role
which he says is perfect for him since
his parents came from Nigeria to the UK
just like the character some of the new
characters you need to know include
Winston's brother Frankie played by Ben
Robson and the overbearing Cormac played
by Mel Gibson now he's the guy running
the Continental in the 70s and has a
strangle hold over the brothers that
basically sets the a whole series in
motion after they decide it's time to
take over and seize control find him
because if you don't I'll bring the
weight of this whole institution down on
you both one of my favorite things about
this show is there's a whole bunch
of women playing what we can only assume
are assassins that includes amateur MMA
fighter and winner of the reality
competition Vietnam Superstar Nung K as
Yen Jessica Elaine from Steven
soderbergh's the laundromat as Lou and
world famous contortionist Marina
mazeppa a runner-up on America's Got
Talent in 2019 as Gretel I mean that is
an arsenal of talent if I do say so
myself can you dig it and in a bit of a
left turn compared to the
villain-centric movies Michelle Prada
plays a detective named KD and is
considered to be the moral center of the
Continental Prada actually previously
starred on Fear The Walking Dead and
Vita wait morals what have you done now
as far as behind the scenes goes the
Continental was developed written and
executive produced by Greg Coolidge Kirk
Ward and Sean Simmons with John Wick
director Chad stachowski serving as an
executive producer and stahlski is
actually the one credited for bringing
in director Albert Hughes who along with
his brother Alan is known for movies
like menace to society and dead
residents I mean in other words he's
legendary Albert said there were several
goals for this show including going
deeper into the rules and mythology
while expanding the physical scope of
the Continental showing fans areas of
the iconic hotel that have actually
never been seen before say no more but
actually I'm going to say a little more
so also directing an episode is
Charlotte branstrom who has worked on
shows like Gray's Anatomy Madame
secretary The Witcher and the Lord of
the Rings the rings of power so to put a
nice bow on it two directors who are
definitely capable of creating and
working in very distinct worlds oh and
one last thing there's gonna be amazing
Easter eggs that'll get you excited if
you're a hardcore WIC fan anyways long
story long get ready to enjoy this high
octane three-part Adventure okay friends
I promise that is officially everything
you need to know before you go watch the
Continental when it hits peacock on
September 22nd also don't forget to
check out the second episode on
September 29th and the 3rd on October
6th my name is nazarez I'm officially
checking out of this Continental thank
you for watching and be sure to rate and
review this show at rottentomatoes.com
and I cannot wait to hear what you think
and what these robes actually look like
[Music]